des feutres et des jeux pour essayer
d'oublier la guerre à qui ceux qui ont
vu leur maison détruites sous les
bombardements peuvent être accueillis
ici
nous aidons les gens à s'intégrer se
rétablir s'intégrer dans une nouvelle
vie réparée
cette ville complètement détruite et
toujours lieu d'une bataille sans
relâche dans l'est de l'Ukraine elle se
rappelle du moment où elle a dû fuir son
logement
le 24 janvier c'est là que l'offensive a
commencé il était impossible pour nous
d'aller dehors on ne pouvait rien faire
nous attendions dans le sous-sol c'est
toujours ce n'était pas aussi difficile
quand l'appartement a brûlé que quand on
nous a fait sortir dehors c'était
beaucoup plus dur
si tout s'experts un jour rentrer chez
eux les bénévoles notent une hausse du
nombre de réfugiés ces derniers mois
avec l'intensification des combats et
puis c'est